كيف سيغير الذكاء الاصطناعي العالم في عام
2030 سؤال طرحته صحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه على ثمانيه خبراء في الذكاء
الاصطناعي والحقيقه ان البعض ايد نظريه
انه قد يقضي على الجنس البشري كاتب سلسله
الخيال العلمي سايلو توقع ان يصبح الذكاء
الاصطناعي قادرا على انتاج افلام كامله في
غضون يوم واحد رئيس قسم الاعمال والحوسبه
في جامعه رافنس بورد في لندن الدكتور عجاز
علي قال ان الاطفال قد يكون لديهم معلم
افتراضي شخصي يقدم لهم دروسا اما عالم
الحاسوب الامريكي اليزيري دو كوفيسكي
فراهن على ان الجنس البشري سيقضى عليه
تماما بحلول الاول من يناير عام 2030 في
حال تجاوز الذكاء الاصطناعي ذكاء البشر
وقال اذا قام شخص ما ببناء ذكاء اصطناعي
قوي للغايه في الظروف الحاليه فاتوقع بعد
وقت قصير ان ينقرض البشر وجميع الكائنات
الحيه البيولوجيه على الارض في موازاه ذلك
يقترح خبراء ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان
يعزز من قيمه الاقتصاد العالمي بمقدار
15.7 تريليون دولار بحلول عام 2030